okay hear me out
so I think that we need to force men to donate their organs
to save all of the kids who are dying on the organ donor list every year
oh no
see so
widely available research demonstrates that
that would have devastating impacts on men
it would increase the male mortality rate
it would keep them in poverty
force them into poverty have devastating impacts on their mental health
and I'm really concerned about like
taking away their bodily autonomy also
we don't even let that happen to dead people
This is what we call a reasonable difference of opinion
that it's terrible public policy
we know it spikes the male mortality rate
I know or our wires are getting crossed here
okay see
so like
2,000 years ago there's a woman in the sky
see her name is goddess
and she has a daughter named Jess
who was like
2,000 years ago on earth and she had these 12 female best friends
and they wrote a book which describes how this is men's duty
so that should clear things up
no to me
you're just describing your imaginary friend and your favorite fictional
old book much more interested in what today's doctors and research shows
We will have to agree to disagree
and I am going to force men to do it anyways